d'exister hier après-midi et hier soir à
la fin des manifestations du 40e
anniversaire de la création de la
République démocratique allemande a été
marqué par des rassemblements
d'opposants à Berlin Est et dans
plusieurs villes d'Allemagne de l'Est
contestation également à la frontière
entre les deux Berlins du côté ouest des
réfugiés s'étaient massés devant le
principal point de passage entre les
deux côtés de la ville Corine pertui
Jean-François
Hoffman check point Charlie hier soir
face à face tendue entre les forces
alliées et la police est allemande
depuis 48h le seul point de passage
entre Berlin Ouest et Berlin Est est
fermé un grand nombre de jeunes réfugiés
d'Allemagne de l'Est viennent d' fêter à
leur manière les 40 ans de la République
démocratique
d'Allemagne au même moment à quelques
centaines de mètres mais de l'autre côté
du mur les manifestations ont une
au CR de liberté et de démocratie ils
sont près de 5000 à défiler sur la place
centrale de Berlin
Est mais à peine le couple gorbachov
reparti vers Moscou la police charge et
disperse violemment la
foule il y aurait de nombreux blessés et
l'on parle d'une centaine
d'arrestation
mais rassemblements semblables ont été
organisés que la répression est la plus
violente les forces de l'ordre
dispersent à coup de matraque les
manifestants le bilan des échaufourés
est encore difficile à établir mais il
est certain qu'au moment où le
gouvernement de Berlin n'arrive pas à
enrayer l'exode de ses réfugiés Eric
oneker aura de plus en plus de mal à
désamorcer la contestation